and also tonight
even cnn
deeply concerned about our economy
under joe biden look at this headline
and we're quoting here
the world may be careening toward a
1970s style energy crisis or worse again
cnn
now joe biden planning a trip to the
middle east as i just mentioned to beg
saudi arabia for more oil according to
joe there's just nothing else that can
be done to increase supply and bring
down prices but as one economist on cnbc
explained that's not really accurate
watch
one of the biggest drivers of this surge
in inflation in recent months has been
energy and there are concrete steps that
the administration could be taking today
to start bringing down some of the the
mid medium to longer run pressure on on
energy prices by increasing permitting
increasing leasing heck if they really
wanted to bring down some near-term
price pressure uh they could be issuing
some jones act waivers but we're not
seeing them do that because it's
evidently politically untenable
yeah you're talking about the rule about
shipping why basically refiners in
houston are going to sell their oil to
the rotterdam netherlands rather than
new jersey because these these weird
shipping regulations uh so there are
concrete steps i see
joining us now with reaction is former
energy secretary and former texas
governor rick perry who knows a lot
about this issue governor secretary
thanks so much for being here tonight
concrete steps that could be taken are
available yet they will not and cannot
do it in the white house why
well i think you heard the reasoning in
the earlier section when you talked
about the
uh the green new deal they believe in
this i mean
they believe that six dollar gas will
stop people from using gasoline and all
it's doing is killing the middle and
lower class in this country i went to a
uh recycling uh facility over in fayette
county texas today pete and and a guy
just started in he said look he said and
this is a this is a guy who's working uh
you know eight ten hours a day putting
in lots of
hours and not making much wages and he's
going to the grocery store and he's
going to the uh gas pump and he's having
to make a difference literally he said
this he said i got to fill up half of my
tank in my truck
because i got to buy food for my family
and he said you know what i'm about to
believe the only people in this country
that are democrats are the rich he said
because us poor folks we're done with
them and i think that was a a real
statement about what's happening in this
country joe biden and all his rich
friends uh all of that woke left uh that
they don't care about six dollar
gasoline they think that's a great thing
but it's killing america and
you heard a little earlier that november
is going to be a moment of reckoning in
this country and it should be
we could be making some changes at the
federal government they know how to do
this they know that you get the
permitting process eased up you open up
those oil fields back up in alaska you
get our offshore leasing going you send
the message to the oil and gas
i know wildcatters and if they think
that they can make a buck out there
they're going to go risk their capital
and do what it takes and they're not
seeing that today they're hearing it
from the
uh the esg crowd at the at the uh you
know with the the corporate entities of
oh you know we don't like fossil fuels
speaking of fossil fuels i want to end
up with this there is a great new book
that's out this week it's called fossil
future by alex epstein i highly
recommend people go get a copy of this
and read it because it makes the case
about if you care about the future of
this world you better care about fossil
fuels and the use of those not only to
keep america safe from a national
security standpoint but also if you're
going to bring people out of poverty
around the world literally billions of
people are counting on fossil fuels to
do it you either hate these people and
don't care if they die or you need to
get on the fossil fuel
bandwagon well i want to dig into that
governor because about the idea of
intentionality that they know it's going
to hurt they they almost they want it to
hurt because if it's six dollars a
gallon 657 bucks they're forcing people
to be not just pinched but squeezed and
then change their livelihoods less
driving less consumption less meat how
would
how do you rational i mean is it really
is it really as simple as
and and i grapple with this myself
they're so obsessed with climate change
and this this this religion of theirs
that they're willing to bring this
economic pain in the short term knowing
in the long term they get the control
they want
yeah they think they can drive people to
the renewable side of things and listen
one of the things that we know pete is
that look all of the above is great we
moved big into the wind energy back in
the early 2000s in texas it was a good
thing uh but it's not
to take over fossil fuels i mean you
need all of the above you need nuclear i
mean if we don't get the nuclear energy
going in this country and around the
world we're done you can't do it with
just wind and solar all you're going to
do is have blackouts and then you're
going to really find out what pain which
we're headed for
which we're headed for all of the above
is an earnest attempt a competitive
environment that says whatever works the
best is going to rise to the top
pressing one in particular and making
people feel pain
that uh
that's ideological and and that's why
they're they're willing to do it
governor where does this go where does
this go in a year or two with people
making decisions about whether to fill
up a half tank
well november is going to be a a big
turnover i think you're not only going
to see the uh the house of
representatives go in a big way maybe
the most
substantial change of seats in the
history of the country and i think the
same thing is going to happen in the
senate where you've got that type of
leadership change and at that particular
point in time uh you can send the
message to the white house hey you're
out of line and we're going to get this
country back and we're going to get
fossil fuels back to where they need to
be
globally that's what's going to happen
mr secretary you're right i look forward
to reading that book there are hundreds
of years of natural resources right in
our own home soil if we were willing to
unleash it uh and and they absolutely
are at war with it rick perry thank you
very much for joining us tonight we
appreciate it use fossil
fuels amen hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else